an environmental catastrophe on the
california coast sandy beaches fouled by
globs of tar shorebirds wading through
wetlands soaked in oil a burst pipeline
from an offshore oil rig gushed half a
million liters of crude into the pacific
from the air the oily sheen covers parts
of the ocean's surface beaches along a
large stretch of coast are now closed we
know that there is
oil ranging from huntington beach and
now we know as far down as laguna
and and likely moving continuing to move
in a southerly direction the area is so
popular with swimmers surfers and
sunbathers that huntington beach is
nicknamed surf city usa coastal
conservation advocates are devastated
you know it's kind of a sense of
you know really sadness and tragedy
combined with the sense that you kind of
knew it's inevitable emergency crews at
sea and on land are laying floating
barriers to try to contain the oil and
prevent even more damage a number of
birds soaked with oil have been rescued
but the impact of the spill will be felt
throughout the ecosystem of beaches and
coastal marshes say environmentalists
it's going to get onto the rocks and
under the rocks
and it's going to also settle in
different places
in the levels of the
the water so there's going to be some on
top they're going to try to skim as much
of that off as they can but some of the
oil could settle to the bottom and just
stay down there for a while the cleanup
will likely take months there are 23 oil
platforms off the california coast all
of them date back at least to the 1980s
for years environmentalists have been
warning that aging oil industry
infrastructure and pipes together with
lacks regulation are a recipe for
disaster
the company that operates the pipeline
texas-based amplify energy emerged from
bankruptcy protection just four years
ago it has a long record of violating
federal environmental laws amplify
energy's ceo says it's unknown what
caused the spill but the pipeline has
been shut down there is no active leak
that we are aware of and especially in
that specific area that we
have identified environmentalists say
the only way to stop future spills is to
shut down the offshore rigs for good
this is a wake-up call that we need to
stop offshore drilling off our coastline
the damaging spill comes amidst a
national effort to switch to clean
sources of energy a major part of
president joe biden's proposed
infrastructure legislation rob reynolds
al jazeera huntington beach california